all right some prop bets for tonight's
game as arizona takes on the seahawks
will caller murray have both a passing
touchdown and a rushing touchdown he is
the first player in nfl history to have
a passing touchdown and a rushing
touchdown in five straight games will he
make it to six chris yes i mean i'm not
betting against them i mean definitely
not and definitely not with what i've
been seeing lately from arizona i mean
first off we know they want to throw the
football but where i give kingsbury a
lot of credit as he's really
like you know running the football and
being patient with it and
like we saw last week and like we've
seen every week then they get close to
the red zone and because they've run the
ball on these drives to get there a
little bit
tyler keeps the ball around the edge and
nobody's there so i would i mean i
almost feel like it's a guarantee he'll
get a touchdown rushing and throwing
tonight that's how silly i feel about it
right now
i love that play they do it's when you
least expect it expected he's in shotgun
there's a running back to his left
everything flows to the right right they
pull the guard
out yeah right he puts the ball out the
running back goes he takes it back and
it's just gone touchdown yeah right i
mean and it and it and it it's
unstoppable and they don't overuse it
right they know exactly when to use it
the defense bites and and you don't have
to swallow the hook it's just a little
nibble right and your flat foot and you
can't get kyler murray that's why
rush attempts are an undervalued number
in the nfl
because the rush attempts are what set
up what you're talking about so that
linebacker think about him he's already
seen whoa kenyon drake kenyon drake
pulling guard kenyon drake and then he's
going okay i've seen it four or five
times in this series i need to get over
there this game guy keeps gushing us for
gashing us for five yards every time
they do it and you get over there
aggressive and that's when he reads it
the right way or they just call it
itself but that's what a running game
does and that's why attempts are
important because it keeps the defense
having to think about it and it's
running game through that that creates a
lot of big plays of the play action and
the quarterback keeps and all of that
the russell wilson question will he have
multiple turnovers whether it be
interception or fumbles lost we asked
points bet for this line using their
name a bet feature they set it at plus
300 that he will have multiple turnovers
bet 100 win 300 what would you take
i think i would go
i would say no
i don't think it'll be multiple i think
he gets one i'll say one
but
i just think there's going to be such a
concentrated effort on and he's just
been so much made about his turnovers
and that's pete carroll who's famous for
you know turnovers turnovers turnout
that's all he talks about so i i would
think that he is going to be extra
careful tonight so i'll say that he does
not get the multiple turnovers
amazing to see that change from the
first five games to the last four from
19 total touchdowns to and three
turnovers to 10 and 10 in the last four
games and they're one and three no
surprise and it all began with that loss
to the arizona cardinals back when they
were 5-0 more receiving yards tonight i
love this one deandre hopkins who had
103 on seven catches when they played
the last time or dk metcalf who had two
catches for 23 yards he had the game
winner that was called back pretty clear
holding call on david moore to pop dk
metcalf free i wonder if he would have
scored without the hold but that one
went away the biggest play for dk the
last time was running down buda baker
100 yards later but uh who has more
receiving yards tonight between those
two well i
we there's a lot of talk right metcalf
of those two receptions and patrick
peterson covered him right and you know
we talked a lot about it and it was a
game where
i faulted russell wilson for that i just
went there was a lot of times he was
open he should have thrown the ball to
dk metcalf and of course would they do
the next week any time they got one on
one they just abused it
if they play the same way tonight
arizona
then man
metcalf is gonna go off i mean if
they're gonna do that i just don't see
how i they don't have the type of corner
that can cover a dk metcalf and i don't
think russell will let them slip by with
the way they played this time
i'm gonna go with hopkins just because i
think arizona's gonna change it up and i
have no faith in seattle's defense and
the waste and the way the cardinals are
running the ball right now and all that
i think i'm gonna go with hopkins yeah
the over under for hopkins is 89 and a
half for dk it's 78 and a half and the
difference the difference this time
tyler lock it's banged up he is expected
to play he missed practice monday well
it wasn't really a monday practice it
was estimated if they had practice he
would have missed it on tuesday he did
miss it with a knee injury but he is
expected to play it was a it was a
locket game the last time he had a huge
performance they were taking advantage
of the fact that dk was being covered
and throwing the ball to tyler locket
they may have to go to dk tonight i
think
you think they're going to like try to
get some revenge with dk again because
they got shut out last week and they're
going to try to do more stuff with them
this week i mean that's that's where i
was having the conversation in my brain
all the talk about dk not getting the
ball again always forces corner in the
corner of the you know forces the oc in
a corner to find more ways to get him
the ball
when you combine what the cardinals did
to dk the last time with what the rams
did to dk just four days ago and it's
the cardinals again
i feel like there's going to be a
concentrated effort to get the ball to
be metcalfe and if there isn't if there
isn't
the seahawks fans need to start
demanding answers from the offensive
coaches because as we've talked about
earlier in the week
it shouldn't be that hard
to find ways to get the ball no hands no
dk metcalf jet sweep put him put him in
the backfield and give him up just give
him a pitch give him your reverse
give him the old-school two-handed
underhand pitch out where they used to
do that they used to do or or the
one-handed spin i used to love that the
pitch out that was the one-handed spiral
yeah into the stomach of the running
back who would just take off with it do
that well i i agreed they they have to
you know hey they haven't had to for the
most part all year because the offense
hasn't been an issue but as they see as
you see every team you're gonna have a
match up the rams we're one of those
cardinals showed it hey we know how to
play you we know how to slow down dk
metcalf watch tonight all those out
there you know dk usually they break the
huddle he lines up in one spot he stays
there that's not how a lot of teams use
their great receivers you know motion
him put them in a bunch put them in a
stack if they want to play man-to-man
make life hard on these guys you said it
speed sweeps reverses watch how many
wide receiver screens deandre hopkins
gets tonight see if dk metcalf ever gets
one because he doesn't really it's very
very rare and i think that's a really a
big part of seattle's offense where it
has to grow in that area so they can
still use dk metcalf and the meat and
potatoes ways that we've seen them use
and keep people off that you know
for the rest of the year
i bet there's a photo somewhere in the
sims archives of phil with his john
denver dutch boy haircut
flipping the ball doing the underhand
spin
pitch out toward the camera classic
quarterback angle he might not be old
enough somewhere he might not be he
might have missed that by like six or
seven years like i feel like those were
like late 60s early 70s playing cards
where
you know he might have just missed those
old poses you know between the pitcher
or the one where the guy like does this
right that's the other one you always
say you're like what a pose that's great
it never happens in a game right never
ever happens in a game but let's go
ahead and have that pose for your
football card yeah all right over under
for tonight is 57 and a half it's the
highest total of the week the last time
they played it was 71. are you over are
you under
yeah it's hard not to pick over i mean
it really is i i i'm still gonna go over
i don't even care i don't
there's a part of me that always goes
thursday night football the teams didn't
have as much time to
game playing on offense and do those
things that hurts it
but i don't care i'm still going over
could the rematch be a disappointment
are we expecting too much from this game
is it going to be like saints tampa bay
where seattle wins 38 to 3.
just some one-sided outcome i would be
shocked i think arizona matches up too
well with with the seattle seahawks i
think arizona to what you said earlier
in the show has a real belief right now
and i think they're looking at it going
man we want to be kings of the nfc west
and of course the seahawks probably
still think they're the kings really
and i think this is going to be intense
tonight i think it's going to be a
little personal i really do i expect it
to be chippy and fun to watch
yeah i i think so too and i really do
believe the cardinals have
just that that aura about them now and
and i'm telling you and it was not a
doctor doom question when i pivoted with
kyler murray to having to turn around
and play in just four days and he would
have played right then that's how badly
he wants this game he wants the
opportunities to prove himself he wants
the chance to become as dominant at the
nfl level as he was at the college level
and he's on his way the guy who
seriously considered playing baseball
and who said earlier this week he'd love
to play both
he he's determined and uh pound for
pound inch for inch i don't think i've
seen more raw determination in a
football player than what calamari has
and i think that's going to be the
difference tonight so that's not my
official pick though the official picks
come later today oh you gave it away i
know who you're going with do you really
think i'm not taking the cardinals after
what week of course sunday after he
helped me avoid
having to buy
a
josh allen jersey and wear it today
although i was kind of looking forward
to it i you know i saved a little money
good and you know i'm cheap you know me
well enough to know i'm cheap that was
my first reaction when you made the bet
i don't want to have to buy a josh allen
jersey wait not only that okay but last
night through a text thread i said man
no no no that's all off the record
it is not now sorry okay
but last night i go yeah we should try
to find more of these type of things
where it's you know a guy you're
passionate about and i'm passionate
about we make these type of bets for the
viewers out there mike didn't want it
he's busy enough he doesn't want to have
to drive down the hill of his driveway
and mail something mail a jersey out we
were talking about
getting the jersey then signing it and
sending it and doing stuff like that
you're just high maintenance you're a
diva you're antonio brown watch
watch the story what happened was you
suggested we do it on a regular basis
pete demelitis chimes in and says yeah
then we could because you wanted nbc to
pay for the jerseys yeah i want to pay
them every tweak
nbc pays for the jerseys and then when
we're done we sign them as if anyone
wants a signed jersey from me we sign
them and we send them to some random fan
that got the pics right or just whatever
the standard would be and i don't have
time to run to the to the uh pack and
ship store
and and mail jerseys all over the
country that's i that's my complaint i
don't care about the money i don't have
the time to screw around with the
administrative stuff and i don't have an
assistant
get in this that's my complaint
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports